bravi ragazzi e benefici da questo nuovo
vino sud e scendere i ragazzi allora il
problema è che è da un po che non ci
gioco perché ormai sarà un passato poi
li settimana quando ho fatto altro
episodio e non mi ricordo i tasti ma
sono andato perfettamente fino a qua
allora call calmi mi ricordo niente dei
tasti tipo come cacchio faccio a salvare
il check point visto che incredibilmente
ce l'avevo fatta ma non saldato c'è poi
come cacchio si faceva lt più l ok a
grazie
meno male che me ne sono accorto dopo
che ho fatto tutto sto pezzo che non
riuscirò più a fare ma che ho fatto
nella incrocio è incredibile non c'è noi
ce la farò mai più cervello giura che
non ce la farò mai più a fare quello che
ho fatto mai ma va bene possibile
amen amen ok ok adesso questo che ok ok
ok ok quest'anno peggio messo peggio va
bene ci siamo addio santissimo allora
non mi ricordo effettivamente nulla e
vabbè mi sembra un po eccessivo
non mi ricordo ragazzi effettivamente il
nulla di quello che ho fatto l'ultima
volta ma so che avevo fatto un buon
punteggio
allora questo lo vedo un po ostico per
il fatto che comunque curvo va bene fa
niente
me ne sono sbattuto va bene l'importante
è arrivare alla destinazione area su cui
non si capisce non si sa con che fisica
ma colonna importante nei giochi non è
importante la fisica che abbiamo già
capito è importante avere culo non
madonna ma speso tantissimo di voto ci
sono passato santo non è vero non c'ero
arrivato ole ole nice
c'era solo un tubo preso quello appena
fa niente
ok ok e devo prendere juan ma donna ho
fatto un disastro perché quando devo
arrivarci con molta più la mia bici è
arrivata va bene vuol dire che meta meta
di noi era arrivato al traguardo vendita
va bene anche prima l'importante che ci
arrivi rapiti poi nevis dio dice che
schiaffo dato ai ragazzi fa niente
allora non ho idea di quanto sia lunga
st mappa ma devo arrivarci convinto
perché vedo che c'è un sacco di gente
che ci sta provando e devo essere
assolutamente superiore per fare questo
non era la superiore
bella bellissima
oddio dio dio dio dio dio dio dio si
vabbè raga mi sembra un po eccessivo se
devo essere sincero se doveste sincero
mi sembra un pelo eccessivo va bene non
fa niente
ma dov'è il casinò devo rimanere nel
mezzo tipo così che ogni tanto mi butto
più avanti no non devo farmi minuti
ma vai che culo che culo
beh va beh non poteva avere non potrà
venne così tanto effettivamente va beh
posso metterci e poi ok ragazzi visto
veramente scusate io mi sto veramente
impegnando cioè questa cosa è veramente
era questione di vita o di morte
cioè io ne va del mio onore visto
veramente facendo un culo quadro perché
è difficile ma ci riesco
e forse anche un pizzico di culo ci
potrebbe anche stare unita tra spetta ok
che un cut bella perfetto perfetto
perfetto perfetto perfetto perfetto
ottimo c'era solo un tubo ha preso
quello aveva niente però stavolta sono
fiducioso nice rai che non sto andando
male non so finction piano allora vorrei
commentarli questa cosa ma non lo
capitano anche io ma va bene siamo
arrivati siamo rimandi arrivando stiamo
arrivando i con gianni morandi al
traguardi in di bella oddio oddio oddio
l'altro messo due ore e mezza a
perseverare aspettano sotto indietro no
aspetta per mi hano ok non devo andare
con sopra nicchiano capivo oddio oddio
mi sembra un po eccessivo qua mi sembra
un po eccessivo
infatti sotto la dietro lo so aspettare
perché io volevo cambiare visuale perché
non vedo come girarmi meticci e poi ok
girati piano che abbiamo
bravissimo bravi non so fare e la
visuale allagati e fotte ok ma sorta non
ha [ __ ] let's go beh ve lo guarda a
guardarla benissimo ma beni non sono
anche come ho fatto arrivare fin qua qua
devo prendere un po di eco esatto di
sprint un po meno forse ho capito ma era
un persona un pirlo era facilissimo era
facile devo solo capire come ci davano
sti cosi però che scarso che sono non
solo capire come ci davano sti affari
non era difficile di fare 1b stop
perfetto very nice
mamma mia che giocata signori che è
giocata signori mi salva come dai
pensavo peggio
madonna che morbello bellissimo e la
moto e vabbè vabbè è che devo capire
come fare questa parte perché ho messo
un circuito in un punto un po un po
maldestro però strumenti abbia in
qualche modo non so come ce la faccio
oddio santo benedetto ok embo mettilo
mettilo l'ho messo messo l'ho messo un
po strano sto c'è poi manomesso
leggo sul finale racca madonna che
cercata non so come dai frati vino
livello per una volta nella vita e ci
credo io ci credo però comunque meglio
del meglio del previsto ma in realtà se
la dobbiamo cioè la faccia che voglio
finirla in corsa vista preoccupi di figo
ma don al dio dov'è finita la mia bici è
finita su marte primo tentativo che ho
fatto la più fa era quello più vicino
grazie grazie grazie
manca 1
[Applauso]
diciotto minuti e zero guarda che guarda
che ne so è per averlo fatto in 18
minuti non era non era facile ai ragazzi
fate sapere se volete altri episodi di
sto gioco perché effettivamente a parte
prendere alberi in faccia io ho finito
di fare quelli degli speciali ma ci sono
ancora altri livelli che sono speciali
ma non solo in stile polgai sono tipo
questi fatti siamo ragazzi se vi piace
io ti porto io vi ringrazio con aver
seguito questo video le mie prodezze
però l'abbiamo visto anche brumotti come
assente ragazzi se video cresciuta solo
questo è un bel mi piace anche vari
social condotta trascrizione io so
ancora giocando come che permette un
gioco una droga e noi ci vediamo appunto
ad un prossimo video dove magari non mi
schianto su un albero da ragazzi
[Musica]